Il variational quantum eigensolver o VQE è uno dei primi algoritmi ibridi quantistico-classici ed è
interessante per diverse ragioni. Primo, come vedremo in questo video, è un approccio promettente per alcuni tipi di problemi. Secondo, è importante
storicamente e ha aperto la strada a molti algoritmi migliorati come adapt VQE.
E infine, il VQE è abbastanza semplice. È facile capire cosa fanno il computer quantistico e quello classico in questo algoritmo
e come interagiscono. Ci sono quattro componenti principali in un calcolo VQE.
Primo, c'è un operatore, spesso un Hamiltoniano, che chiameremo H, che descrive una proprietà del sistema che
desideri ottimizzare. Un altro modo di dire questo è che stai cercando l'autovettore di questo operatore che
corrisponde all'autovalore minimo. Spesso chiamiamo quell'autovettore lo stato fondamentale.
Poi c'è un ansatz, parola che significa approccio. Questo è un circuit quantistico che prepara uno stato quantistico che approssima
l'autovettore che stai cercando. In realtà, l'ansatz è una famiglia di circuit quantistici perché alcune delle gate nel
ansatz sono parametrizzate. Cioè, ricevono un parametro che possiamo variare. Questa famiglia di circuit quantistici
può preparare una famiglia di stati quantistici che approssimano lo stato fondamentale.
Poi, abbiamo bisogno di un estimator, un mezzo per stimare il valore di aspettazione dell'operatore H sullo stato quantistico
variazionale corrente. A volte ciò che ci interessa davvero è semplicemente questo valore di aspettazione, che
chiamiamo funzione di costo. Altre volte ci interessa una funzione più complicata che può comunque essere scritta partendo da
uno o più valori di aspettazione.
Infine, abbiamo bisogno di un ottimizzatore classico, un algoritmo che varia i parametri per cercare di minimizzare questa funzione di costo.
Delineiamo il problema che vogliamo risolvere e l'approccio generale prima di affrontare il ruolo del quantistico. Possiamo
formulare molti problemi di ottimizzazione critici per la scienza e l'industria come problemi di autovalori di matrici. Comunemente, vuoi
l'autovalore minimo della tua matrice e l'autovettore che gli corrisponde. La matrice H potrebbe essere
un Hamiltoniano che descrive l'energia di un sistema fisico. E l'autovalore minimo sarebbe l'energia dello stato fondamentale
E0 e l'autovettore sarebbe il corrispondente stato quantistico fondamentale, spesso indicato come psi sub 0.
Oppure la matrice potrebbe descrivere una funzione di costo complicata associata a problemi di ottimizzazione combinatoria
come nella logistica, e l'autostato s sub opt sarebbe una soluzione ottimale del
problema, come una stringa binaria che etichetta un taglio in un grafo di una rete di distribuzione. In pratica è
comune sentire il termine Hamiltoniano usato per tutte le matrici di interesse, anche al di fuori delle scienze fisiche. Diciamo che
siamo interessati a una matrice con n righe e n colonne. Tali problemi possono essere risolti rapidamente e in modo esatto usando
solutori classici per n fino a qualche centinaio o migliaio, senza ipotesi sulla matrice. Per matrici
sparse, quelle con per lo più zeri come voci, questo può essere molto più grande, con n fino a un miliardo anche su un laptop.
Ma per problemi veramente enormi che superano questi numeri, sono spesso necessari metodi approssimati o euristici.
Più grande è la matrice e meno sparsa, più il problema è intrattabile e più trucchi ingegnosi devono essere impiegati. Supponi che la tua matrice sia così
grande che la diagonalizzazione esatta non è un'opzione. Supponi inoltre di conoscere abbastanza del tuo problema da poter
fare alcune ipotesi sulla struttura complessiva dello stato target e di voler esplorare stati simili alla tua
ipotesi iniziale per vedere se il costo o l'energia può essere ulteriormente ridotto. Questo è un approccio variazionale ed è un metodo
che si usa quando la diagonalizzazione esatta non è un'opzione con un computer classico. Funzionerebbe così.
Primo, fai un'ipotesi sullo stato con alcuni parametri theta che varierai.
Anche se questa ipotesi iniziale potrebbe essere casuale, non è consigliabile. Vogliamo usare la conoscenza del problema in esame
per adattare la nostra ipotesi il più possibile.
Secondo, calcoleresti il valore di aspettazione dell'operatore con il sistema in quello stato.
Terzo, modificheresti i parametri variazionali e ripeteresti.
Quarto, useresti le informazioni accumulate sul panorama degli stati possibili nel tuo sottospazio variazionale per fare ipotesi sempre migliori
e avvicinarti allo stato target.
Il principio variazionale garantisce che il nostro stato variazionale non può produrre un autovalore inferiore a quello dello
stato fondamentale target. Quindi più basso è il valore di aspettazione, migliore è la nostra approssimazione dello stato fondamentale.
Parliamo della difficoltà di ogni passo in questo approccio.
Impostare o aggiornare i parametri è computazionalmente facile. La difficoltà sta nel selezionare parametri iniziali utili e
fisicamente motivati. Usare le informazioni accumulate dalle iterazioni precedenti per aggiornare i parametri in modo
da avvicinarsi allo stato fondamentale non è banale. Ma esistono algoritmi di ottimizzazione classica che lo fanno
in modo piuttosto efficiente. Questa ottimizzazione classica è costosa solo perché può richiedere molte
iterazioni. Nel caso peggiore, il numero di iterazioni può crescere esponenzialmente con n.
Il singolo passo computazionalmente più costoso è quasi certamente il calcolo del valore di aspettazione della matrice usando un
dato stato. La matrice n per n deve agire sul vettore di n elementi, il che corrisponde a un ordine di n al quadrato
operazioni di moltiplicazione nel caso peggiore. Questo deve essere fatto ad ogni iterazione dei parametri. Per matrici estremamente
grandi, questo ha un alto costo computazionale. Ora immagina di delegare questa porzione del
calcolo a un computer quantistico. Invece di calcolare questo valore di aspettazione, lo stimi preparando lo
stato s di theta sul computer quantistico usando il tuo ansatz variazionale e poi effettuando misurazioni.
Analizziamo un po'. H in generale non è facile da misurare. Per esempio, potrebbe essere composto da molti
operatori di Pauli x, y e z non commutanti.
Ma H può essere scritto come una combinazione lineare di termini H sub alpha, ciascuno dei quali è facilmente misurabile. Per esempio,
operatori di Pauli o gruppi di operatori di Pauli che commutano a livello di bit. Il
valore di aspettazione di H sullo stato s è la somma pesata dei valori di aspettazione dei termini costituenti H alpha.
Questa espressione vale per qualsiasi stato s, ma la useremo specificamente con il nostro stato variazionale s di theta.
Ciascuno dei termini h alpha può essere misurato m volte producendo campioni di misurazione s sub alpha j con j che va da
1 a m, e restituisce un valore di aspettazione e una deviazione standard. Possiamo sommare
questi termini e propagare gli errori attraverso la somma.
Questo non richiede moltiplicazioni su larga scala né alcun processo che necessariamente scala come n al quadrato. Invece,
richiede misurazioni multiple sul computer quantistico. Se non ne servono troppe, questo approccio potrebbe essere
efficiente. E questa è la parte quantistica del VQE. Ma parliamo dei motivi per cui questo potrebbe non essere efficiente. Un motivo
per molte misurazioni è ridurre l'incertezza statistica nelle tue stime per calcoli ad altissima
precisione. Un altro motivo è il numero di stringhe di Pauli necessarie per coprire l'intera matrice. Poiché le matrici di Pauli più
l'identità coprono lo spazio di tutti gli operatori di una data dimensione, è garantito
che possiamo scrivere la nostra matrice di interesse come una somma pesata di operatori di Pauli come abbiamo fatto prima. Qui c alpha è un
coefficiente numerico e H alpha è una stringa di operatori di Pauli che agiscono su tutti i qubit che descrivono il tuo sistema.
H alpha avrebbe una forma del genere, dove l'n-esimo operatore di Pauli da destra agisce sull'n-esimo qubit. Quindi possiamo
misurare il nostro operatore misurando una serie di operatori di Pauli. Ma non possiamo misurare tutti quegli operatori di Pauli
simultaneamente. Gli operatori di Pauli, escludendo l'identità, non commutano tra loro se sono
associati allo stesso qubit. Per esempio, possiamo misurare I Z, IIZ e ZZ
XZ simultaneamente perché possiamo misurare I e Z simultaneamente per il terzo
qubit. E possiamo conoscere I e X simultaneamente per il primo qubit. Ma non possiamo
misurare tutti Z e Z, ZZ, ZX simultaneamente perché Z e X non
commutano ed entrambi agiscono sul qubit zero.
Quindi decomponiamo la nostra matrice H in una somma di operatori di Pauli che agiscono su qubit diversi.
Alcuni elementi di quella somma possono essere misurati tutti insieme. Lo chiamiamo un gruppo di Pauli commutanti. A seconda di
quanti termini non commutanti ci sono, potremmo aver bisogno di molti di questi gruppi. Chiamiamo il numero di tali gruppi di
Pauli commutanti t.
Se ngcp è piccolo, questo potrebbe funzionare bene.
Se H ha milioni di gruppi, questo non sarà utile. Registri il valore di aspettazione o la funzione di costo
per l'insieme di parametri theta usato nel tuo stato e poi aggiorni i parametri nel tempo. Potresti usare i
valori di aspettazione o i valori della funzione di costo che hai stimato per approssimare un gradiente della tua funzione di costo nel
sottospazio degli stati campionati dal tuo ansatz.
Esistono sia ottimizzatori classici basati sul gradiente che senza gradiente. Entrambi soffrono di potenziali problemi di allenabilità come
minimi locali multipli e grandi regioni dello spazio dei parametri con gradiente quasi nullo chiamate barren plateau.
Quindi il VQE risolverà tutti i tuoi problemi più difficili? No. Ma essere migliore in tutti i calcoli non è mai stato lo scopo. Abbiamo
spostato ciò che determina il costo computazionale. Guarda cosa abbiamo scambiato. Siamo passati da un processo
la cui complessità dipende solo dalla dimensione della matrice a uno che dipende dalla precisione richiesta e dal numero di
operatori di Pauli non commutanti che compongono la matrice. Quest'ultimo aspetto non ha analogie nel calcolo classico.
Sulla base di queste nuove dipendenze, per matrici sparse o matrici che coinvolgono poche stringhe di Pauli non commutanti, questo
processo può essere utile. È il caso dei sistemi di spin interagenti. Per esempio, per matrici dense, potrebbe essere
meno utile. Sappiamo, per esempio, che i sistemi chimici hanno spesso Hamiltoniani che coinvolgono centinaia, migliaia, persino
milioni di stringhe di Pauli. È stato fatto un lavoro interessante per ridurre questo numero di termini, ma
i sistemi chimici potrebbero essere più adatti ad alcuni degli altri algoritmi che discuteremo in questo corso.
L'uso efficace del VQE richiede anche di conoscere gli attributi del nostro stato target e di poter selezionare un buon
stato iniziale fisicamente motivato così come un buon ansatz con relativamente pochi parametri variazionali. Questo può essere
piuttosto impegnativo. Il VQE dimostra come i punti di forza dei computer classici e quantistici possano essere combinati.
Senza aggiungere metodi più recenti, il VQE non ci aiuta a risolvere problemi intrattabili per i computer classici, ma
continua a svolgere un ruolo nello sviluppo degli algoritmi. E il VQE ci insegna anche che trasferire un passo dal classico
al quantistico non è né migliore né peggiore per tutti gli scopi. Piuttosto,
cambia quali fattori determinano l'efficienza del tuo algoritmo. Questa è una lezione generale importante nel calcolo
ibrido quantistico-classico.